[Musica]
[Applausi]
by
[Musica]
Sto
chiamando, sto
chiamando,
non mi senti
[Musica]
infin
PL [
Musica] [
Musica]
for
[Musica] [
Musica]
[Musica]
foree
cap
GPS
per
spingersi nella piazza del mercato
erano appena arrivate tante notizie materne
ci restavano 5 anni per piangere
senza cielo piangeva e ci diceva che
la terra stava davvero
morendo piangeva così tanto che aveva la faccia
bagnata poi sapevo che non stava
mentendo sentivo i telefoni  teatro dell'opera
ogni melodia così ragazzi giocattoli elettrici
C e TV il mio cervello era come un magazzino
e non avevo spazio libero dovevo stipare così tante
cose per riporre tutto lì dentro e
tutte le
persone grasse e magre tutte le persone alte e basse
persone nessuno tutti  quella
gente non avrei mai pensato di aver bisogno di così tante
persone
una ragazza della mia età è
impazzita lui dei
bambini piccoli se il nero non l'avesse
scacciata penso che li avrebbe uccisi
un soldato con il braccio rotto fissava
lo sguardo sul  le ruote di una
Cadillac una tazza e baciare i piedi di un
prete e un qu ha vomitato alla vista di
th Credo di averti visto in una
gelateria a bere frappè C e a
sorridere a lungo e a salutare e ad avere un aspetto così
bello, non crederti  sapevo che eri
nella canzone e faceva freddo e pioveva
così mi sono sentito un attore e ho pensato al
mio e volevo riavere lì il tuo
viso la tua razza il modo in cui parli ti
bacio sei bella ti voglio  per
camminare ci sono rimasti cinque anni bloccati negli occhi
cinque anni che sorpresa abbiamo avuto cinque
anni mi fa molto male il cervello cinque anni è
così abbiamo abbiamo cinque anni che mi sono rimasti
sugli occhi cinque anni che sorpresa abbiamo
avuto cinque anni mi fa male il cervello  tanti cinque
anni questo è tutto quello che abbiamo abbiamo cinque
anni St sui miei occhi cinque anni che
sorpresa abbiamo avuto cinque anni mi fa
molto male il cervello
cinque anni è
tutto vieni
con noi a salpare e combattere per la
vita [
Musica]
[Musica]
[Musica] [
Musica]
sì
[Musica]
vieni con noi per salpare e combattere, abbiamo
un'ultima possibilità di salvarci la vita, noi
siamo quelli, noi siamo quelli
[Musica]
ow ah ah ow ow ah
ah
ow
per
Baler
[Music]
e
Kings sei un brutto
defunto vivere in uno stato di
paura mi circondava di un Tre e sto
mangiando tutti i tuoi alberi di Natale con l'
ancoraggio della
lattina Ti inseguirò sotto la pioggia senza
compromessi in questo Bain  Prendo il
controllo in un posto dove non c'è
ritorno ad ogni
passo e
prendo un amico il
giorno Baleniere nella
neve Manderò un SOS al
mondo potete chiamarmi
M Affondando Baleniere nel mare ora c'è
un
antropologo che piange  Sto analizzando le sue
teorie sul
controllo in un luogo dove non c'è
ritorno ciascuno lì un
giorno l'oan fre of bre e il
[Musica]
[Musica] [
Musica]
giorno
no [
Musica]
[Risate]
oh
[Musica]
tu  devo
combattere
[Musica]
Ho una piccola
signora oh solo una piccola signora nella
mia volontà B tutto e
domani quando avrò un'ora sotto la pioggia
purtroppo un po' di
champagne dolce niente può tirarmi indietro, noi
uomini, per volare attraverso questo
universo, tu non lo fai  non ti importa niente
non ti importa niente volerai
devi combattere devi
combattere Non ho paura di perdere Perché
dovrei attenermi alle tue regole è la mia
vita che
vinco
oggi tu no  non me ne frega niente
sei più forte di quanto lontano volerai devi
combattere devi
combattere Non ho paura di perdere Perché
dovrei attenermi alle tue regole Non
ho paura di perderlo, lo
capisco
[Musica]
attraverso la
non ti importa niente di tutto ciò sei
più forte della caduta è la tua
vita devi combattere devi
combattere
sì
devi
[Applausi]
combattere
per
[Musica] il
tempo il
tempo sta aspettando nel  ali di cui parla
Cose senza senso è roba da poco, siamo io e
te, ragazzi, il tempo si flette come una [ __ ], cade
snobbando a
terra, il trucco, siamo io e
te,
ragazzi, dime in quut e vino rosso
chiedendo bambole Billy e altri
miei amici prenditi il ​​tuo
tempo, il cecchino dentro  il
cervello che
rigurgita
drena incesto e Vain e molti
altri nomi oh guardo l'orologio dice
9:25 e penso oh Dio sono ancora vivo
dovremmo essere in onda entro
[Musica]
ora dovremmo essere in onda entro
[  Musica]
ora la la la la la la la la la la la la la
non sei una vittima, urla e basta, tesoro,
non sei una vittima
[Musica] ora [Musica
]
Gesù, brava, sembri vecchia, griderai,
cattura  un raffreddore perché hai lasciato il
cappotto dietro prenditi il ​​tuo
tempo separarsi è difficile ma restare al
buio è
odioso ho fatto così tanti sogni ho fatto così
tante scoperte ma tu il mio amore per la
gentilezza l'amore ti ha lasciato
senza sogni la porta dei sogni era chiusa il
tuo parco era  davvero senza sogni forse
stai sorridendo ora sorridendo attraverso questa
oscurità quando tutto quello che dovevo dare era l'
abilità di
sognare dovremmo essere in questo momento
[Musica] la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la
la  la la la la la la la
tempo
vedi
temp gra
[Applausi]
Gra